سأنتقل الآن إلى مالكولم ديفيس في
أديليد بأستراليا، فهو أحد كبار محللي
الإستراتيجية الدفاعية والقدرات في
معهد السياسة الإستراتيجية الأسترالي، شكرًا جزيلاً لوجودك هنا
معنا، لذلك سمعنا من
بيكي حول رد فعل إسرائيل حتى الآن، لذلك
أريد  لأسألك أين يتجه هذا الأمر
لإسرائيل ما هو هدفهم
هنا حسنًا يجب أن يكون هدفهم هو هزيمة
حماس بشكل حاسم في أم غزة أه
وإنقاذ وتحرير أكبر عدد
ممكن من الرهائن الذين
اختطفتهم حماس في أم  في نفس
الوقت عليهم أن يدركوا أن الأمر
لن يكون سهلاً أم أن
البيئة العملياتية في غزة كثيفة بشكل لا يصدق وحضرية
آه
وستكون في الأساس قتالًا من منزل إلى منزل من شارع إلى شارع
أه لذا أه فإن
عمل قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية مقطوع بالنسبة لهم
في هذا الصدد ولكني لا أرى أي
بديل للإسرائيليين غير
الذهاب إلى غزة وهزيمة
حماس بشكل حاسم وتدميرها بشكل أساسي نعم
تحدثت عن إنقاذ الرهائن أه
نحن نعلم أن القوات الخاصة الإسرائيلية
لديها قدرات هائلة لكننا
سمعنا من ضابط سابق  مسؤول وكالة المخابرات المركزية
قال بشكل أساسي إنهم لن يكونوا قادرين على
إنقاذهم بأمان أم هل تشاركهم
هذا الرأي أم تعتقد أنهم
يستطيعون بالفعل استخراجهم؟ قد نحصل على
عدد قليل منهم ولكن لسوء الحظ أعتقد أن شخص وكالة المخابرات المركزية
وأنا أستمع  بالنسبة لتعليقاته
السابقة، أعتقد أنه على صواب، كما تعلم،
أعتقد أن أه ربما ما
حدث هو أن هؤلاء الرهائن قد
انتشروا الآن في جميع أنحاء غزة بعيدًا
عن خطوط التقدم الإسرائيلية قدر
الإمكان، ولذلك سيكون من
الصعب جدًا  اذهب إلى هؤلاء
الأشخاص للتعرف على مكان وجودهم
ثم أنقذهم للأسف، أنت تتحدث
عن كون غزة
منطقة ذات كثافة سكانية عالية تزيد عن 2 مليون شخص أه
مجرد كابوس من وجهة
نظر عسكرية كيف يدخل الجيش الإسرائيلي
إلى هناك ودون إلحاق الضرر
خسائر فادحة في صفوف المدنيين، كما تعلمون،
الحرب البرية في المناطق الحضرية هي أصعب حرب
يمكن أن تتخيلها لهذه
الأسباب، فهي تعلم أن الشوارع الضيقة آه آه
مربكة آه تخطيط الشوارع التي
يختلط فيها المدنيون بالمقاتلين آه
المباني مثالية
بالنسبة لك كما تعلم  دفاع متعمق من قبل حماس،
لذا فإن ما يجب على جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي فعله هو
الذهاب من منزل إلى منزل
وتطهير حماس من كل مبنى
على طول خط التقدم إلى غزة، ولا
يوجد سوى خطوط قليلة للتقدم عند النظر إلى الخريطة مسبقًا
إلى
غزة من إسرائيل، لذلك ستكون
عملية صعبة بشكل لا يصدق أه
من الواضح أنها ستدعم من
الجو ولكن بعد ذلك يتعين على الإسرائيليين اتخاذ
جميع الاحتياطات اللازمة لتجنب وقوع
إصابات في صفوف المدنيين على عكس حماس التي
لا تهتم حقًا بتجنب
وقوع إصابات في صفوف المدنيين باستثناء  لذلك أعتقد أنه يمثل
تحديًا هناك، نعم ومن الواضح أن
حماس كانت تعرف ما هي
العواقب العسكرية لذلك،
ما مدى استعدادها، هل تعتقد،
ما رأيك في
قدراتها أم هل نعرف حتى
بالنظر إلى النطاق  العملية
التي رأيناها للتو فاجأت الجميع تقريبًا
أعتقد أن هذه نقطة جيدة
أعني نوعًا ما أه من الواضح أن المخابرات الإسرائيلية
فشلت فشلاً ذريعًا في التعرف على
الاستعدادات لهذا الهجوم
فهل نفهم بالضبط ما
حصلت عليه حماس أه ربما  دول مثل إيران
زودتهم
بقدرات إضافية لا
يعلم عنها الإسرائيليون لذلك أعتقد أن أه هو
تحدي لدرجة أنهم يسيرون في
العمى يعني لديهم
وسائل تكنولوجية يمكن أن تساعدهم في تحديد
الأهداف وربما أه  احصل على
نظرة ثاقبة على
قدرات العدو ولكن
مساحة المعركة أكثر غموضًا أه وتعقيدًا التي
يخوضها الإسرائيليون، فأنت تعرف
الحرب المدرعة على مرتفعات جوان على سبيل
المثال نعم، وأخيرًا سمعنا هناك
من بيكي تعرف قذائف الهاون أه  الهجمات التي يتم
إطلاقها من أه من حزب الله ما
رأيك في الاحتمال أن أه
يمكن أن يتطور هذا إلى حرب إقليمية أوسع
حسنًا، أكره أن أقول ذلك ولكن أعتقد أن
الاحتمال كبير جدًا، فنحن
نشهد بالفعل هجمات من هيسبار
عبر الحدود إلى الشمال  إسرائيل
أه أعتقد أن هناك كل الدلائل على
أن حزب الله ينوي الدخول في
الحرب بشكل صحيح بمجرد دخول جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي إلى
الغرب إلى غزة لذا من
المفارقات أن ترى حرب جبهات ثلاثية مع
الإسرائيليين يقاتلون في الجنوب وغزة
أه يقاتلون حزب الله أه في  الشمال
وربما القوات الفلسطينية في
الضفة الغربية وحزب الله لديهم
أعداد كبيرة من الخدمة مقابل صواريخ متطورة جداً وأكثر
تقدماً بكثير
مما حصلت عليه حماس أه
ويمكن أن يحدثوا أضراراً جسيمة ويوقعوا
خسائر فادحة في الشعب الإسرائيلي
والآخر  البعد الذي يجب أن نكون على
دراية به هو بالطبع
البعد الإيراني لأن إيران تدعم كلاً من
حماس وحزب الله وبالتالي فإن احتمال أن
تتجاوز هذه الحرب حزب الله
لتشمل إيران أعتقد أنه حقيقي تمامًا